I'm Rafael Goncalves.
I'm a research scientist at
the Stanford Center
for Biomedical
Informatics Research
at Stanford
University. And in this talk,
I will describe
software developed
by the Protege team and how
various collaborations between
our team and industry have led
to substantial
improvements and
to new functionality
in the protege
software. I'll describe what
these new features are,
how people have
worked with them,
and where our team
is going from here.
The Protege team
at Stanford has
been developing
and maintaining
knowledge
representation software
since the very
early nineties.
It all started
with the Protege
desktop tool,
which is a platform
independent open
source software
for building ontologies.
Protege has an extensible
architecture that allows third
party developers to
create plugins,
which enhance
the core functionality
of the Prodigy software.
About twelve years ago,
the Prodigy team realized that
there was a need
for a tool that
facilitated real
time collaboration
between ontology,
ontology developers
and subject
matter experts.
So the protege team developed
Web Protege, a web
based ontology
editor that is
rich with features
for collaboration,
and it has a simplified user
interface for
ontology editing.
So nowadays, our team supports
two different yet
complementary tools,
the desktop protege
and web protege.
In this talk, I will focus on
web protege.
I'll just say
a few words about
the protege user community.
Over three hundred and sixty
five thousand users
have registered
to download protege software,
although we don't
don't require
them to do so. Over twenty one
thousand users subscribe to
protege mailing
lists to receive
announcements,
user or developer
support. Our users actually
support each other
through these
mailing lists. Sometimes even
before we get to read
the help requests.
Protege tools are used in all
sorts of settings
in academia,
in industry, and
in government.
With a community
as diverse and
large as a protege
user base and
with protege being
an open source tool,
and it is easily extendable,
This has meant that there have
been numerous
codes and plug in
contributions from
protege users
and from third
party developers
throughout the years.
Web protege shown here in this
figure is a modern web based
ontology editing environment.
Essentially, it
is a Google Docs
for ontologies.
In short, ontologies
are machine
processable artifacts that
represent
the important concepts
and the relationships
that hold
between these concepts in some
domain of discourse.
Web protege is an open
source project.
It is licensed
under the BSD two
clause license,
and it is free for
everyone to use.
The figure here shows the main
Web Protege user interface
displaying the so
called Aero project.
This project bears no relation
to any of the ontologies or
knowledge graphs
that I'll mention
later. It is used here merely
for illustration purposes.
The left hand side
of this figure
displays the class hierarchy
containing various
tagged classes.
The center display displays
the content for
the selected class.
In this case, we have selected
l ten eleven, and this frame
shows us everything
that the ontology
has about this entity.
The right hand side displays
threaded discussions
for the selected
class, and it shows
recent editing
as well as commenting activity
that has occurred throughout
the project.
We provide a hosted
solution for
the community at
webproject dot
stanford dot edu,
where anyone can
create ontology
projects. People just need to
sign up and create
an account.
As of this week,
we have over seventy thousand
registered Web Prodigy users,
and we have just
over a hundred
thousand projects
on this hosted
version of Web Prodigy.
Besides the hosted version,
we produce releases that third
parties can download
and run privately.
This is typically how industry
users such as Cisco
and Pinterest
have deployed Protege
Web Protege site.
Web Protege was designed to
allow users to collaboratively
edit ontologies, much
like Google Docs.
It features various aids for
collaboration, and I'll just
give you a flavor
for these here.
We have change tracking.
Changes are tracked
by user, entity,
and timestamp, and they are
replayable so that they can be
used for
producing intermediate
versions of projects or for
computing diffs or for rolling
back changes.
The tool also provides high
level descriptions
of the changes
that occurred,
which are designed
to make it easier for users to
browse and to
understand the changes
that have happened.
WebRagee provides a simple but
very effective issue
tracking system.
Users can post
discussion threads
per object and
these discussion
threads can be
managed and they
can be resolved
in a way similar
to traditional
issue trackers.
We also have hooks
in the system
for change notifications.
Users can be
notified of changes
to the ontology,
changes to parts
of the ontology,
posted discussions,
etcetera over Slack
and via email.
So that is a very
quick overview
of Web Protege.
Now we'll go into a few more
details later.
The language that Web Protege
works with is called OWL.
That is the Web
Ontology Language.
It is the latest standard in
ontology language languages,
and it is the most
used ontology
language worldwide.
An OWL ontology
is simply a set
of statements,
and we call these
statements axioms.
I'm not going to say much more
else about OWL,
except that
the language itself
is highly expressive,
and it provides a rich set of
primitives and
constructors for
building expressive
ontologies.
And it's a World Wide Web
Consortium standards
with the World
Wide Web Consortium
being the key
standards body for
web technologies
from HTML and CSS through to
knowledge
representation languages
like RDF and OWL.
One of the goals
of Web Protege
is to tame
the complexity of OWL
and the intimidation
factor that
this complexity
brings with it.
To this end, Web
Protege provides
quite a simple user interface
out of the box.
Class descriptions
and individual
descriptions are
simply displayed
as frames of information.
In this slide,
you see the simple
frame based display
of information
in web protege
on the left hand
side and the underlying
OWL code
on the right hand side.
I don't I don't expect you to
read these OWL axioms.
I just want you to notice that
OWL is an expressive ontology
language and that
there is a fair
amount of complexity
under the hoods
that we do our best to shield
our users from.
Historically, the majority of
the funding for the protege
project has come
from the National
Institutes of Health.
We have also received funding
from the National
Cancer Institute
in the US as protege is their
editing platform
for the National
Cancer Institute Thesaurus or
NCI Thesaurus for short.
For a long time,
our primary focus
has therefore
been on supporting
the biomedical
ontology engineering
community.
We've actually led the way in
terms of producing application
oriented ontologies such as
the gene ontology
or the ontology
about chemical entities of
biological interest
or KEBI for short,
among many other ontologies.
However, more recently we have
been seeing more
and more interest
in the use of
Protege for ontology
editing in commercial
settings.
Commercial ontologies
or knowledge
bases which are also known as
knowledge graphs
tend to be much
larger than what we,
the Prolocea team,
have traditionally
been used to
working with.
In recent talks
at the Knowledge
Graph Conference and
the International
Semantic Web Conference,
I described the collaboration
between our group
and Pinterest
on building on
an ontology that
forms the core
of the Pinterest
knowledge graph.
I won't go into detail here
about the engineering
of the Pinterest
graph, but instead,
I'll briefly describe the Web
Project features
that we developed
to improve its construction,
maintenance, and curation.
After that, I'll
describe the kinds
of functionality
that we've been
building in WebRTC
to facilitate
the engineering
of the Elsevier
medical knowledge graph and of
the BASF chemical
knowledge graph.
A feature that
has been heavily
used in the development
of the Pinterest
ontology is called
entity tags.
These tags can be used to
highlight entities
in a colorful
way in the WebRagee
user interface.
Each tag is assigned a label,
an optional description,
and a color,
as you can see here
in this screenshot.
These tags can then either be
manually assigned to entities
or they can be automatically
assigned in an, live
query based way.
Tags can be
automatically assigned
to entities in
an ontology based
on structural criteria as I'm
depicting here
in this figure.
This tagging feature
supports complex,
multiple conjunctive,
and disjunctive criteria along
with paths of values
to be matched.
Here the automated tagging
criteria specify that any
subclasses of Airbus aircraft
that are missing a value for
SCUS definition will be tagged
with a tag called
missing definition.
It is then possible to search
for entities that have been
tagged with a specific tag or
with multiple tags.
This can be done
using the traditional
search feature in the WebRTC
tool by typing the tag name in
the search text field.
The entity tags feature was
adopted by other users fairly
quickly and this screenshot is
an example of that.
I'm showing here
a public ontology
developed by Highways England
which is currently maintained
in Web Prodigy.
As you can see the ontology
developers have made extensive
use of entity tags throughout
the ontology.
Note also that
the tags are not
only displayed in the class
hierarchy in
the left hand side
of the user interface,
but they're also displayed at
the top of the entity
description view,
which is shown
here on the right
hand side of the figure.
Another key feature that was
essential for
Pinterest curators
was having support
for multiple
languages in
the user interface.
In particular,
it was essential
to display entity
names in a secondary
language across the class
hierarchy as depicted in this
screenshot. Here,
the primary display
language is
English and
the secondary display
language is Hungarian.
The secondary display name is
shown to the right
of the primary
display name.
The colorful tag that you see
in the UI with hu highlights
the classes that are
missing a Hungarian
label. So one way or another,
entities that are
missing labels
can be easily identified
in my protege.
Finally, during
our collaboration
with Pinterest,
we built a querying mechanism
and the user interface,
which caters to
the most common
kinds of queries that users
perform in ontologies.
In this screenshot,
we are searching
for subclasses
of Airbus aircraft
that contain
the string passenger in their
labels and
the results are shown
at the bottom of this figure.
The expressivity
of the queries
that can be done here comes
close to a shackle core
implementation
disguised in a user
friendly form.
About a year ago,
we released this
graph visualization
interface shown in
this figure here.
The graph displays all
of the relationships
that a selected entity,
in this case
the Airbus aircraft
A350 is the subject of.
Subclass of relationships are
shown in solid yellow,
while custom relationships are
shown in blue,
such as the primary
manufacturer of
Airbus aircraft.
When exploring
tools to edit and
to curate the Elsevier medical
knowledge graph,
Web Protege came
up as a natural
candidate. This feature in
particular was of interest to
the Elsevier team
as it provides
a useful bird's eye view of
the relationships
that hold for
a particular entity without
overwhelming the user too much
with information from
other entities.
Because of the enormous amount
of relationships that a given
entity can be involved in,
the graph visualization can
become difficult to browse and
to navigate, in particular for
extremely large ontologies or
knowledge graphs.
So in collaboration
with Elsevier,
we have developed a mechanism
to specify and
to apply filters
to the graph visualization.
Each filter has a name,
a status that is whether it is
active or not
from the get go,
an optional description and
definitions of
what edges should
or should not be included in
the visualization.
We can add multiple
criteria for
inclusion or
exclusion of content
in the graph. For example,
here we have two filters
in this figure.
The first filter specifies
inclusion of subclass of edges
and exclusion of edges where
the head node is deprecated or
where the tail node does not
have a label on it.
These were just examples.
The second filter specifies
inclusion of edges
where the edge
property is engine
configuration.
Applying these filters,
just described to
the visualization
shown in the earlier slides,
we get the graph
in this figure.
Notice that
the applied filters
are listed at the bottom of
the user interface and we can
add or remove these filters
quite easily. Finally,
it is possible to
export the content
of the graph
visualization from
Web Protege in
the form of an SVG
vector image file.
Now all the functionality that
I've mentioned up until now is
included in a live version of
Web Produce. So if you
log on to it now,
you will see all of this.
Now the work that
I'll describe
next will are
features that are
under development currently.
And so you won't see
them straight away,
but they will appear
in the future.
Beyond the standard editing
interface in Web Protege,
we have been
building functionality
that makes it
possible to create
forms for viewing
and for editing
entities in an ontology.
We've been doing this work in
collaboration with Elsevier.
We use these forms for subject
matter experts to view and to
curate content in the graph.
We can add customizable form
based presentations and simple
visualizations that provide
controlled knowledge entry.
They also provide an efficient
and pleasing way to browse
ontologies for
both experts and
unexperienced users alike.
Forms are displayed
upon the selection
of entities that
match specific
criteria similar
to the way that
entity tags can be
assigned to entities.
The form here displays an easy
to view and to
edit presentation
of the logical description of
selected classes.
In this case, the amino acid
alanine from an ontology about
amino acids.
In this and the next slides,
I'm briefly going
to demonstrate
the creation of the amino acid
form that I just
showed you before.
So in this form,
we start by defining a field
that represents the name of
the object with
a default language
English. It's possible to add
some optional help
text to each field.
We then specify how the value
for this field binds
into the ontology.
In this case, we define that
the value will become
a relationship
value of the selected
subject.
Remember that a specific form
gets activated when we select
an entity that
triggers that form,
and that this entity
is the subject
of the relationships
defined in
the form unless we
otherwise state it.
Other options here would be to
bind acquired information to
the parents, to
instances or to
subclasses of
the selected entity.
We can specify common form
settings such as optionality,
that is whether the field is
required or optional
and repeatability,
that is whether
the field appears
only once or multiple
times in the form.
Then we can choose
what happens
if the selected entity
gets deprecated,
how the form fields,
will get displayed in the form
interface, And finally,
what kind of form
field this is.
In our case, this
is just a simple
text field.
In this portion of the form,
we are creating
the charge form field.
Remember that this field only
has three possible
values negative,
neutral, or positive.
First, the input
value for this
field is specified to bind to
the hasCharge property.
This means that
the input value
will become the filler or in
other words,
the object of a hasCharge
relationship.
The other major
difference between
this field and
the previous one
is that this is
specified as a single
choice type field,
which gets displayed
in the interface
as a segmented radio button.
The possible options
for the form
field can be specified
to be a fixed
set of values or they can be
drawn from the existing values
in ontology in a dynamic way.
In this case, we
are specifying
that the possible options for
the charge field
are the subclasses
of the charge class
in this ontology.
So the options are dynamically
populated from
ontology content.
After we specify
the other fields
to acquire
the information that
is intended to define an amino
acids we end up
with a complete
amino acid form,
which I'm showing
you here again
in the middle, view
of the WebProtein
user interface.
And so this wraps up the core
of the work that we have been
doing in collaboration
with Elsevier.
The next and
last collaboration
I'll mention is with BASF,
the largest chemical producer
in the world.
The National Cancer Institute
disorders is an ontology that
we would traditionally
call large.
It contains over
two and a half
million axioms that describe
over a hundred and fifty seven
thousand classes.
Now when we come to the BASF
chemistry ontology,
it is in a league of its own.
Out of all the enterprise
ontologies that we have seen,
the BSF chemistry ontology is
by far the largest.
From our point of view,
it is tremendously large.
It contains over seven hundred
million axioms.
That's seven hundred million
axioms that describe
over thirty
million classes.
So what this means
is that the BASF
ontology is three orders of
magnitude larger in terms of
axioms than what
Webproject was
originally designed for.
So the challenge is on.
The good news is
that BASF have
successfully used Neo4j for
holding the chemistry
ontology.
So we proceeded down the route
of re engineering web protege
so that it can
interface with Neo4j.
Now to to achieve this,
we set out to design a mapping
between the web
ontology language,
OWL, and labeled
property graphs
supported by Neo4j.
We also produced a software
library that allows
us and other
people to extract, transform,
and to load ontologies into
Neo4j graphs.
And this library
also allows us
to view and to manipulate
manipulate Neo4j
graphs through
the lens of ontologies.
Now, although we
have used Neo4j
as a backend technology
in this project,
the architecture that we built
into Web Protege
is very flexible.
So in principle,
Web Protege can
be made to work
with any backend
graph database.
We have designed
and implemented
the very first comprehensive
mapping between ontologies and
Neo4j graphs.
This allows us to
store arbitrary
ontologies in Neo4j.
Our approach to representing
ontologies in Neo4j knowledge
graphs means that
we can capture
anything that can be expressed
in the L2 language.
It's a clean and uniform
representation that is easy to
query and it's
also bidirectional
mapping so that we can round
trip ontologies to and from
Neo4j graphs without any loss
of information.
I'd like to note that while
there have been
previous efforts
at representing ontologies in
Neo4j graphs or
labeled property
graphs in general,
these efforts have
been somewhat
narrowly focused and they are
either severely
limited in what
can be expressed,
in other words they are not
complete for
the OWL language,
or they're single
directional mappings,
meaning that ontologies cannot
be round tripped
from the labeled
property graph format,
or these
representations are at
the wrong level
of abstraction,
meaning that they would be
extremely verbose
and hard to manage.
We then re engineered
Web Prodge
so that it can interface with
Neo four j, and this gives us
the ability to display and to
edit extremely large knowledge
graphs in Web Protege.
I'll say again
that the chemistry
ontology developed by DSF is
three orders of
magnitude larger
than anything that
we have dealt
with before.
Our initial investigations
indicate that Neo4j can handle
the chemical ontology with our
chosen representation.
And we note that Web Produce
with Neo4j backing
it is responsive
enough for browsing and for
editing an ontology
of this size.
Finally, although
we have focused
on Neo4j graphs,
the representation
that we came
up with is not
specific to Neo4j.
It would work in
any store that
is capable of
supporting labeled
par property graphs.
The main point here is that we
can now map OWL
ontologies into
labeled property graphs,
and Web4j can be made to work
with a back end
graph database.
To wrap up, I'll now give you
a glimpse of what we've got
planned for next year.
First off, we plan to release
the customizable forms feature
that I discussed.
Next, we hope to
support identity
management using
Keycloak so we
can allow common
single sign on
options such as
Google accounts.
We then plan to
implement support
in the WebRTC
user interface as
well as APIs to
support curation,
reviewing, and issue
tracking workflows.
A last feature that
gets requested
a lot is finer grained user
access control.
So we plan to provide support
for customizing user roles and
to tie those into specific
ontology operations.
Finally, as we gain
more experience
with editing
enormous ontologies
in Web Protege,
we expect to implement major
enhancements to
the user interface
to accommodate
the visualization
and management of content of
such magnitude.
And with that, I would like to
thank the organizers
for having me,
and I'll take any
questions. Thank you.
What what can you
do in Prodigi
Desktop that is
not possible in
Web Prodigi and, vice versa?
That's a great question.
So Protege Desktop
was designed
as a expert system
where you can
do pretty much
anything that you
might think of
with ontologies.
And that includes
in particular
reasoning. Protege has protege
desktop has by
default reasoning
support, and it
has this plugin
architecture that has allowed
other developers
to to build and
to contribute
reasoners that can
be used, within
protege desktop.
We also have
different querying
mechanisms in in
the desktop version.
And as a and we've also got
justification systems that,
allow you to ask
why is it that
the particular axiom
holds or is true.
And and these features are not
in the web version
of of protege.
So web protege
does not currently
have reasoning support,
and the querying capability is
that which I've shown you here
in this presentation.
Now Web Protege
does have a lot
of other things
that the desktop
version doesn't have.
And this is very
much what you've
seen in this presentation.
So the tagging
system is not in
the desktop version.
The forms are not
in the latest
version of Protege desktop.
It used to be that
there was a version
of Prodigi that had
a form system.
But in the latest iteration of
the desktop version,
that's no longer true.
So forms will be
exclusively in
the web version
of Web Prodigi.
And we've also got this entity
based visualization,
in Web Protege
where you select
an entity and you see
all the relationships
focused on that
entity outwards.
In Protege, we do
have visualization
plugins that have
been contributed
by the community.
But these tend to
be visualizations
of the entire ontology.
So you get a lot
of information
there and oftentimes this is
just too much to handle.
In my protege we've discovered
that even an entity based
visualization is already too
much in many cases.
And we've had to develop this
filters mechanism,
to cater to that.
And so, to have
a visualization
of the whole
ontology in desktop
protege, is helpful,
but only in certain
scenarios.
And Web Protege
takes that a few
steps further,
by providing all
of the flexibility that I've
described here.
So it sounds a little like,
Protege was
the experimentation
platform, and Web
Protege is taking,
like, the best,
the best of that,
the best practices,
and implementing
them in a coherent
tool. That's at least what I'm
feeling now.
So use of Skoast.
That's why Protege supports
support the use of Skost.
So in general,
Protege and Web Protege
are OWL tools.
And, and so we play
by the semantics
of OWL.
So while we can use COS as,
non logical parts
of the ontologies
so as to have annotations,
cause annotations,
for example,
for labels, preferred labels,
definitions, and whatnot.
We the the tools themselves,
are only work with
our semantics.
So they will not so it's cost
narrower or broader,
are not catered to in
in Prodigia tools.
But you can use
terms from this
cost vocabulary in,
in our ontologies.
And so that's the that's
the compatibility
that is provided. Great.
Thank you for your answer.
So a lot of excitement
around the forms,
in in the questions.
And, so, the first question,
from Olivier is, forms
are for classes,
right, not for instances.
Forms can be for
classes and for
instances. In this in this new
form system that
we've built in
Web Produce,
we've we've
designed it so that
it can acquire information not
just about classes,
but individuals
as well and and
it can actually,
it can actually
acquire information
that describe not
just one entity,
but multiple entities.
So if you wanted to acquire
information about
the subclasses
of Airbus aircraft,
as you saw in
the screenshot in
the figure, we can
actually do that.
So we can describe classes,
individuals, or collections of
these in some cases. Great.
And what's
the release date for
the forms and,
is there a better
version we can
play with? So this
is a good point.
As you know, all
of the project,
all of the software that we do
is open source.
So if you actually go on to
the Web Protege,
GitHub repository,
you'll find this forums,
feature is is in a branch of
the Web Protege, codebase.
So you can absolutely,
experiment with it,
install your own
version of a protege
with the forms branch and and
play around with it.
It is not yet live,
and we don't expect
it to be this year,
but we do expect
to release it,
in the first quarter of twenty
twenty one.
We don't have a fixed date,
but but in the next
few months,
we would hope to have it.
But in the meantime,
you can experiment with it.
And it's quite easy to install
your own version of AprylGA in
your own system.
And, we're always here
to help in case.
Thank you.
Couple questions
about the BASF,
ontology, the chemistry,
ontology.
Frederick asked
if the ontology
is open and available?
No. So all of these,
both the Pinterest
and the Elsevier
and the BSF knowledge graphs
that we've been,
working with,
they're all, proprietary.
So we, they're not
open to the public.
We basically can
describe the kinds
of of work that we did to,
allow these companies to,
engineer and
curate their their
knowledge graphs,
but we can't describe
their content,
unfortunately.
So I've heard in
your vocabulary
the use of the switch
from ontology to
knowledge graph
on a fluid continuum,
and especially for this BASF.
So you call it
a knowledge graph.
So my question was,
so these seven hundred million
axioms actually are
ontology instances,
right? They are
entities of a knowledge
graph. Is that correct?
That is correct.
Yes. So so all of these thirty
million classes or so that are
described by these
seven hundred
million axioms,
they're all at the,
class level. They're they're,
they include public ontologies
such as the gene ontology or
this chemical entities for
biological interest ontology
because these can be
reused to define,
chemicals that are of
interest to BASF.
And so
the representation itself
is very much at
the OWL level.
Not a lot of instance data.
But but to go back to the flow
between ontologies and
knowledge graphs,
I have done it in a I've said
this in a way that ontologies
are typically used as a,
as the basis for
the construction
of of these knowledge graphs.
Or at least it has
been in the cases
that we've been dealing with.
So Pinterest for example has
built an ontology,
and then they have
other databases
from which they extract
relationships that
connect these
databases to the ontology.
So everything
becomes one giant
knowledge graph that includes
a logic based
representation of
the the things
of most interest
and the logical
definitions that
can be done. And
those that are
of interest for reasoning,
those are expressed in OWL.
And then you've
got these other
bits of information coming in
from other databases,
which are basically
like triples.
And and these will
bridge the gap
between sort of relational
databases or other kinds of
databases and ontology level,
knowledge. And this is sort of
the same in in in BASF and and
Elsevier where
they want to have
a high level description of
entities in their domain and
have that be the basis upon
which they interlink all of
the data in their
databases that can be,
and that they are
interested in
mapping to ontologies
and querying,
using ontologies.
Great. Thank you.
We're we're almost,
out of time.
Maybe one one small question
from Daniel. Is there any plan
to add a graphical editing
functionality? I'm not exactly
sure how to interpret that.
Maybe directly on the graph
visualization would
be the question.
So basically,
sort of like drag
and dropping things
in the in the graph?
Inside like grapho. So yes.
That that would be drag and
dropping notes and
relationships.
Right. Right. So
at the moment,
we don't have,
any plan to to do
this sort of,
to have this kind of support,
basically, because
we've not really had,
a lot of interest in it.
And so,
there has been
interest in doing
things like bulk operations in
an ontology.
And this was
something actually
recent that I
didn't mention but
that we did in
the Pinterest work.
Because it was
it was useful to
be able to take a chunk
of the ontology
and just sort of
like subclasses
an entire tree and
just put that onto,
another part of
the hierarchy.
And that is possible.
But we've not had
much requests
for the other way around doing
this sort of fine grained drag
and drop things in the graph.
Although we can
totally see that
it might be desirable
in many cases,
we've not had much
push for it.
But we'd be happy
to consider it.